How cool would it be to get a text file
and then run some kind of processing
that outputs your handwriting? And I
know what you're thinking. CG Matter,
did you just describe a handwriting
font? Listen, I know these exist, but
this is different because not only is it
your own handwriting, but it's going to
randomize each letter. So, not every
letter A is going to be the same as the
next. Every letter K or whatever is
going to be varied. This video is
sponsored by Squarespace, and we're
going to talk about that later. So, the
first thing we need is we need to write
some stuff. I have my paper. I I should
have a pen. That's a pretty critical
part of this when you say for each
letter I'm going to write let's say
three variants to start. So I'm going to
have the letter A and then I'm going to
write it again and then again. Now these
are all going to be slightly different
from each other. Not majorly but enough
that it's not registering. Wow, this is
the same one each time. And I could even
deliberately kind of mess up one of
these letters so that they don't look
perfect. And I'm just going to go down
the list here. If you want capitals, you
also have to make a capital letter set.
[music] And same with numbers, etc.
Jeez, that was painful. I'm only going
for lowercase. Our next step, of course,
is going to be scanning this in. Drop
that bad boy in here. This isn't a
printer tutorial because I I don't even
know how to use my own. Well, it's doing
something. Okay, let's see what we got
on the old computer. So, PNG. Too many
settings. Don't care. Okay, so here we
have our image. It's fairly high
resolution, which is good. I wanted to
have that texture. One of the big
problems here is some letters are like
wider than others. So, for example, you
could say this a letter D quite skinny.
Doesn't take a lot of horizontal space.
whereas something like a I don't know
it's like the worst offender and M is
much wider. We somehow need to isolate
the letters but beyond that have them be
different widths. This is going to suck.
Inside of I'm going to import in
my image. And we're first going to do
some processing to the image. And then
we're going to isolate letter by letter.
So for the overall processing, I don't
need this to be transparent or anything.
For all of these, let's first of all get
rid of any unintentional color. So you
can see here there's some like uh RGB
noise. I'm going to get rid of that. And
then the next thing is you could
threshold it, but the thing about
thresholding is you're going to kind of
lose all of your detail, right? It's
just a black or white mask, whereas
there should be kind of those
transparency values. So, I'm thinking
let's run a levels on this where I could
bring up the black. I guess I'm really
just increasing the contrast, right? And
if there are some kind of like pixels
over here that survive for some reason,
I'll just call that some graphite spill,
right? That actually adds detail. And
now the very painful process of letter
by letter. This might be a good time to
use like OCR detection. I'm going to
make a selection. And the goal is to
really get the bounds of the letter.
Okay. I don't want to leave extra space
where it isn't needed. So just kind of
find the minimum or smallest bounding
box. And then once you've isolated a
letter, how do we kind of treat this? We
go to image. We go to crop to selection.
And now we have our letter file, export
as inside of our letter folder. I'm
going to call this A cuz it's the letter
A_1 cuz it's the first instance. We're
going to have 1 2 3 and JPEG's fine with
me. This is like a trash. I don't know
50x 50 pixel image. Anyways, you go to
the next one and you you put on a
podcast. And just in case you're doing
this along with me, let's pick a YouTube
video together. The problem with the
humanoid robot. Okay, this will do. See
you in a minute. That took a
legitimately aggravating amount of time
and I just did the lowercase letters.
This is the folder of everything I made.
So, you can see a sub 1, a sub 2, a sub3
all the way to z sub 1, 2, and three.
Also, you'll note that I made these
three like blank ones, which I should
probably rename. This represents space,
as in there's a gap between letters. And
you might think, why are there three of
them? They're identical. It just makes
the math easy since we want to randomize
a choice between like three for each
letter. So, I figured there can be three
white spaces. Who cares? So, now our
goal is basically to make a geometry
node system that takes a piece of text
and figures out not only which letters
should be there, but it should randomize
the selection. and it has to put them in
an order and with a spacing that makes
sense. You don't have letters
intersecting. One has to follow another
and it has to somehow keep an index of
how long down the line I've written.
There's kind of like a limitation in geo
nodes like importer for images. It
doesn't let you use file paths. So, for
now, I'm just going to use the import
images as planes add-on. If you don't
have it enabled, then do that. I'm just
going to select all of these. And
really, the end game is just to have it
be like an alpha channel thing. I think
shadeless is what we want. maybe even
emission. I don't even know. Good enough
for me. Import images as planes. And
now, not only does it import in all our
letters, which it does. But notice that
they keep their like relative sizes. And
you're going to see a big issue right
now. But before I address that, uh you
can see the I's are thin, the L's are
thin, etc., and it goes all the way down
the line. Now, what's the big issue? The
issue is my dumb dumb brain didn't
actually write these to scale. So, this
letter A here is much bigger than I
would normally write it compared to the
letter D. Kind of that circle here. So,
because these aren't relative to scale,
relative to each other, I need to fix
that manually, but it's not a big deal.
The way I see it is there's two kinds of
letters. There's like tall letters like
B, D, F, G, whatever. And then there's
like circular letters like A, C, E. All
I'm going to do is I'm going to select
those ones. So, the C's qualify, the E's
qualify, M's are too big, N's are too
big, O's are too big. Are WX's, not Y,
but yes, Z. They're the not tall
vertical letters. I'm going to hit tab
so that I can scale them, but I don't
want to scale them as one thing. I want
to scale them individually. Individual
origins is going to allow me to do that.
And it looks like I have skipped one of
these. So, I just kind of scale it until
it roughly fits. We can also modify
these one by one. So, one of our C's is
bigger than the other. Yeah, that's
pretty good. I think the only thing
missing is eyes are kind of small
actually, even though they're vertical.
So, let me make those tinier. Now that
we have our whole thing, one thing I
want you to notice, and this is very
important. You're going to see that this
like list of items is in order
alphabetically, literally, cuz it's the
alphabet. And this is going to be
important because when we distinguish
between which one is which, we're going
to be looking for its index in the
collection. So, if this is not in order,
we're going to have a bad time. I'm
going to close up this collection and
I'm going to call it my alphabet. And we
also need a object to be our like geo
nodes thing. That should be outside the
collection. I'll call this our compiler.
Really, it's our writer. I'm gonna hide
that and I think we're good to go. We
want to make sure that all of these
aren't like centered where they are
currently. So if I was to draw a line,
right? So I'm writing on top of this
line. You can see these A's are exactly
where they should be, but the B's are
under. And what the freaky is going on
with the C. Some letters dip above or
below. So the G's need to be a lot
lower. I want to adjust this in a pretty
fast way. And for most of these letters,
except for the G's, Q's, and P's, the
ones that, and J's, the ones that dip
under, I think we want to center it at
the bottom left corner for each of
these. We're in geo nodes land, baby.
So, that was cringy. So, let's hide our
alphabet. Go to my geo nodes area. Get
rid of the input and the header. First
of all, we need to bring in our things.
That's going to be our collection. So,
you can make it go into a collection
info, but we don't need it. So, just
collection info. Bring in our alphabet.
And when we view this, you're going to
see it brings everything in in the
positioning and the ordering that you
know we had. As we can see in the
spreadsheet here, we have a single
instance. It should not be one instance.
We need 26 letters, 27 with the space
times three instances. So you're going
to hit separate children. And now we
have all of our things with its like
names and our instances. Turns out
there's 81. And I guess we could also
reset the children, which will overlap
all of them. Now, here you can really
see this issue I'm talking about where
some of the letters are above the line,
some of them are below it. And our goal
really is for each of these tiles,
whatever letter it may be, whether it's
tall or skinny or whatever, we need this
to be centered at like the bottom left
corner. So, right now, it's centered at
the origin. I just want to shift
everything up. We don't know how to do
it, but we do know our goal is to
translate our instances. And we just
need to find that magical number for
each of these. There's that new node
called bounding instance bounds. And
what it does is for each instance
individually, it's a field. It will give
us the minimum and the maximum. The
minimum corresponds to the bottom left
corner. I believe if I was to translate
each instance by its individual minimum,
you can see now they are all like
centered at the top right corner. Why is
that the case? If I have my tile over
here that's centered and I look at its
minimum, if I offset by this minimum,
it's going to shove it this way. Really,
what I want to do is the opposite. I
want to take this bottom left corner and
make it the origin. So, you might
already know all we need to do is run
that vector math where we invert. We
multiply by negative 1 and beautiful.
Now, they are all where they need to be.
But again, there is a tiny bit of a
problem. It's the special letters, the
Y's, the P's, the ones that dip under
our writing line. And we could move
those down using geo nodes, but I think
this is the kind of thing that's easier
to do manually. So, another new operator
that will help us with this is if we
select our geometry nodes and hit Ctrl
A, there's a new operator called visual
geometry to objects. When I click it,
you're going to see it has this special
property where it made all these
collections and all of these objects.
It's now taken our things with the
transforms, but made them each of them a
separate instance, a separate object,
which is exactly what we want. I'm going
to take our writer that is right there
in the middle of the alphabet and I'm
going to put it in a new collection
called writer to be more organized and
so that we don't see it here. We can
take all of these like instant instanced
collections or whatever and this time I
believe Ctrl+ A and now make instances
real. So now these are all objects and
the empties are separate. I'm going to
also select our writer which is the geo
nodes. Ctrl I to invert and select
everything else and delete it I believe.
And now all of these collections, I
don't know what they represent to be
honest. If I take all of these empty,
well, they're not empty. I take all of
these collections, I rightclick, and I
delete hierarchy. That should have
gotten rid of them. Okay, so the only
objects we have is our instances that
are now well positioned, and we can
align them. So, I'm going to call it
corner alphabet or something. We have
our corner alphabet that has 81 objects.
We have our writer, that's the geonotes,
and then we have our good old alphabet
that we no longer need, but I'll keep it
around. So now the name of the game
really is to figure out which letters
need to go down. And that is pretty
simple because I know which letters
those should be. Well, I can actually
just look at my sheet here. So looking
at this, the first ones are the G's
followed by the J's should also be
beneath. The P's and the Q's and then
the Y's. And that should be it. All of
these should be lower. So I'm just going
to shift these down like that. So
they're right on the line. And now
they're all centered where they need to
be. I can hide the corner alphabet and
now we construct words. Okay, we've done
it. So, as I have mentioned or at least
will mention, a lot of the nodes in this
tutorial are going to be available free
at cgmatter.com. A website made with
Squarespace. So, why do I choose
Squarespace to host and make my website
for the use case I'm going for, it's an
obvious choice. The first thing that is
huge is Squarespace payments. All the
logistics of selling and having
recurring subscriptions is handled by
them. Payments right on there. Second of
all, you have an asset browser, which is
important because I have like photos, I
have videos, and I have blend files in
my uh posts in the member only area. And
then thirdly, I was actually recently
writing some documentation for the
camera tracker update, and I found that
the built-in Squarespace AI stuff is
very intuitive in finishing your
sentences, kind of knowing what you
meant. I went in there, I did a second
pass to be like, "Oh, here's something a
bit more specific." And the great thing
is you can try Squarespace. Make your
own website. And when you're ready to
launch, use this link below in the
description to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or a domain. I'm
going to add a new object. This one,
what should I name this? Well, the
writer, I mean, this new one should be
the writer. So, maybe we can call this
the aggregator. I don't even know. This
one can be the writer. And then this
needs its own geometry nodes. Just like
before, we're going to import in our
collection this time of the corner
alphabet that is positioned where it
needs to be. You can see that once again
this is a single instance. I don't want
that. I want to separate children. So
now I have all of my 81 letters. I think
I forgot to put the origin at world
cursor which is what we were supposed to
do. But there's a very easy way to clear
these positions so that they stay where
they are but their position is zero. To
do that I'm going to make them no longer
instances. I'm going to realize
instances. So now these are all going to
be faces but they're going to be in the
exact same order which is what is going
to let us bring it back into instances.
So got rid of the data. bringing it back
to instances and to separate them they
need to be separated by index for the
faces. So now once again we have a one
of these and just to verify that
everything is in the correct order I'm
going to run a separate by index which
is a node I made and you can get for
free. You don't need to be a website
member although I encourage you to be.
This is going to let us separate by in
this case instance and I can go through
these. So the first three should be
empty. The next three should be A's and
then B's and they're all the correct
size. C Let's write a word. So I'm going
to make a string. That string can say
something like CG matter, which isn't
only a good word in general in this
world, but it has two T's over here,
which is going to let me test that
randomization of can you pick different
T's or whatever. For each letter, one by
one, it needs to detect what letter it
is and bring in the corresponding
instance. Now, this is a operation for
the repeat zone cuz I want to repeat
going down the line. I forgot I was
using 4.5. We're in 5.0. I just like the
look of it. So, what was I saying? I was
saying we're going to take all of this.
We're going to control G make that a
node group alphabet, right? It's just
like a list of instances. And now we can
run a repeat operation where it's going
to separate letter by letter and bring
in the correct instance. We are going to
loop over the string. And each um
iteration, the string is going to stay
the same. So I'm just going to feed it
into itself. And the number of
iterations is going to be the number of
letters cuz we need to go letter by
letter. So let's do a string length.
That'll tell me exactly how many letters
and therefore how many iterations to go
through. And then for each iteration I
need to figure out which like index is
the letter C, the letter G, the letter
M. So if we just like write the alphabet
like in a column generally you might be
like okay A is 1, B is 2, C is 3 etc.
Although the only difference is now
there are actually three A's and three
B's and three C's cuz we made those
variants. You can think of A as being
like 1 through 3 or like 0 to two
whatever you want to call it. B is going
to be 4 to 6 and yada yada. Uh that's
what we need to capture. If I type in
the alphabet just in order A B CDE E F G
H I J K L M N O P Q R S T U V W X Y Z
and maybe let's also add a space at the
very beginning. So that's going to
represent like the zero with the space
letter. I can then take each letter and
compare it to the string and say where
is it in here there is a like find in
string. I bring in my string. I say what
is it that I want to search and then it
will give me the index of where it found
it. We need to separate this out to its
first letter and that can be done using
a slice string. So many string nodes
that we haven't really played with. I'm
going to bring in our string and then
for each iteration I want to say look at
the iteration as the position. So maybe
position one is C, position 2 is G, yada
yada yada and only keep the first one.
So if for like CG matter I was at
position two which represents G. The
length is how many letters am I going to
keep after that? So if it's a length of
one it's just going to be G. If it's a
length of two, it's going to be the G
and the M. So, where do we start and how
many uh do we go down? Of course, we
only want a length of one because we
only want that letter. This is what I'm
going to search for. So, we're going to
find where is it in this thing. This is
going to be the index. And then we do
that multiply by three situation. I
guess we have integer math. Take the
index, you multiply by three. We might
need to add one somewhere. I don't even
know. And then for this, remember the
name of the game was uh bringing in that
instance, whatever it may be. And we'll
also add that like can it pick a
different variation in a moment. I just
want to see generally does this work. So
for the alphabet I'm going to use that
separate by index again that's on my
website for free. We are going to take
this and separate the instance such that
it is equal to whatever this is. So it's
going to output like the instance of C
or G or M whatever. I want to join it
with everything that it did before. So
I'll explain this right now. We start
off with a target string. In this case
it's CG matter. I take the length of it
to say how many letters do I need to
process and then for each iteration I'm
going to take position 1 2 3 basically
this iteration this index I'm going to
keep only that letter nothing beyond
that and then I'm going to find it
inside of our alphabet including a space
it's going to tell us where in that
string is it going to be and then
because we have three variations I
multiply by three and pull in that
index. So this may be wrong but let's do
a big reveal. I'm going to do this and I
mean it kind of looks right. There's a
T. There's a G. Never mind that they're
all overlapping. I think it's bringing
in the right letters. What we can do is
we can take the letters and for each
iteration, I'm just going to shift them
to the side. Eventually, we need to
figure out what that perfect amount is.
But for now, I'm just going to transform
geometry. And that translation, where am
I moving them? That can just be the uh
iteration or index. So, we have CG M A T
E R. And notice that these T's are
identical, which is what we expect. It's
pulling in the exact same one. Well, if
we have three values of t, I believe
right now we're always sampling the
first one, but I want the chance to
offset by one or offset by two. So, it
can pick a variation. What is that
variation going to be? Well, all I need
to do is I need to add a random value.
And maybe this could be integer math. It
really doesn't matter. Add a random
value. That random value has to be a
integer between zero and two. If it's
zero, it's saying pick the first. If
it's one, offset by one, offset by two.
connect this over here which you can see
changed things a little and it also
broke things a little and I think we
must have like have the index like
shifted by one which is why letters are
you know phasing in and out but either
way I want to make sure either the seed
or the ID is different each time what
happens if we take our iteration and
make the seed different versus ID so now
you can see in some cases we get
different T's that aren't identical as I
change the seed we get a flickering of
the letters where it chooses the right
one but maybe a different instance of it
beautiful I think it's time to clean
clean up shop. All of this stuff that
essentially selects the uh string can be
a node group. And because we're using
this input multiple times, select all of
this. Ctrl G. And then we can call this
our I guess our like index finder or our
position finder. The input is going to
be the iteration, which I'm just going
to make it nice and readable. That's
been one of my new hobbies. Kind of a
strong word, but I've been trying to
organize my files a bit better,
especially since I'm going to ultimately
share them this part right here. So, we
have our index finder. This part right
here is going to be our like letter
selector, I guess. So, letter selector.
And then we have our transform geometry,
which right now doesn't make any sense.
They're just going diagonally. So, I'm
going to get rid of that for now. I'm
going to select all of this. CtrlG. And
this could be called Well, what does it
do? It basically takes in a string and
it outputs all of those instances. So
maybe we'll call this gather instances
or maybe gather letters which in here we
can specify that this is a instance
output with a input of a string. So now
the last task really is we need these
letters to go one after another which
isn't as obvious as saying translate by
like 2 every single iteration because
some letters as you can see here are
skinnier longer than others. So this M
that you can barely see from CG matter
is longer than the G is going to be for
example. It needs to detect like the
horizontal length of each of these and
then say put one after another then
calculate the whole length. Put one
after another. Calculate the whole
length. Blender veterans geo nodes
veterans will know I just describe the
accumulate field node. What it does is
it adds things. What it adds is up to
us. And in this case what I want to add
is if I have a letter what is its
horizontal width? Well, width is always
horizontal because these are instances.
Again, I'm going to use that instance
bounds node. Very useful. I'm going to
take the minimum or no, the maximum
minus the minimum. So, I'm going to
subtract these. The way you want to
interpret this is there is a maximum top
right corner. There's a minimum. This
vector goes from one to the other. And
if I just look at its like x component,
I project it down here. That is the
width. We're going to separate the x
component. This is what I want to add.
But what am I adding? I'm adding over
instances. That was not what I meant to
do. we're adding over instances. And now
what this accumulate field will let us
do is it doesn't just tell us the total,
but it has this leading and trailing
thing. I don't remember which is which,
but this is basically going to say what
is our progress as we add these
instances. So I'm going to take
something that can take in a field like
translate instances. Now this can be
different depending on the index. So
that's how we got our diagonal thing.
These are inverted. We'll think about
that later. And that translation should
only be on the X component. So I'm going
to say this is our translation. And then
the X component. It's either leading or
trailing. I never remember. So leading
does that. What about trailing? It is
inverted. It is. And we'll fix that. But
like you can see exactly where one
letter ends. The next one begins.
Amazing. And if I was to change this, so
I bring in a different string like
default. I haven't tested out the space.
So this is a good time to do that.
Default cube. Amazing. Default space
cube. And at this point you might be
thinking, is it opposite day? Should I
mirror this whole video? There are two
solutions to this. So one obvious
solution is to write this backwards. So
instead of default cube it would be
ubebeck. I got to turn on my brain for
this one. T L A no TLF. This is so hard.
Okay default cube. So one thing we can
do is we can invert the string which
sounds pretty stupid but I do believe I
made a node for this. So is it reverse
string? I do have a node for this and
this will work. How are you doing? But
uh kind of like a more obvious solution
is before we do this accumulation
whatever we need to take these instances
that go through one to well whatever we
have as many instances as we do and we
want to take their indexing and flip it
so it starts with the last one first.
Good old sort elements node coming to
the rescue. Before I do that however we
do have another node group available to
us. So I'm just going to select all of
this G. This is going to be like our gap
compiler or something. What about
translator? Something like that. And now
all we need to do is we have a string,
we gathered all the letters, we
translate it, but it doesn't like
translate it like Google translate.
Okay, positioning. And what's the point?
The point is we need to reverse these.
So by default, the way this works is it
takes in some sort weight. So that tells
you what am I using to list these. So by
default, it essentially you can think of
it as using the index. So if the index
is you know 1 2 3 etc. It will use that
order to again make a 1 2 3 etc. So,
what if instead of going 1 2 3, we take
these and we just multiply them by - 1.
So, instead of 1 2 3, it's going to be -
1 -2 -3. Well, it wants to go from
smallest to largest, which means it's
going to start all the way here at like
-12 and then work its way upwards. That
is a uh reverse. So, that's super easy
to do. Multiply by 1 and there you go.
Let's take all this, make it a group.
I'm going to call this, you know,
reverse reverse or maybe reverse order.
At the end of all my tutorials, OG
people will know I always said I've and
notice I'm not using this apostrophe,
nor am I using capital letters because
we do not have that covered, but
whatever. So, I've There we go. Been
okay, let's just do it all. I've been CG
matter. You've been you. Goodbye. Now,
this is kind of surreal to me because I
know my my own handwriting and this is
what it would look like. And to see it
in like perspective, cuz right now we
have this background and it just kind of
looks jagged. I'm going to turn off
overlays and let's make the background
that we're seeing, we can make that
white. So, in the properties or in the
shading, I'm going to do the properties.
We can set the world color to white. And
then to see that, you can either go to
rendered mode. I'm going to go back to
lookdev mode. You can enable scene
world. The nice thing about this
procedural approach is that it is that
it is procedural. So, if I see that my
O's are too big and I only give big O's.
You can select all of those and then I'm
going to go to edit mode. Although now
we do want to scale to the world origin
over here, don't we? So let's kind of
scale to the 3D cursor. So that's going
to make it like this. And let's see what
that does. That not only shrinks the
O's, but now you can see the spacing
adjusts automatically. I'm seeing my E
are still huge. And you know me, I
always like my huge E. Uh, I'm going to
scale that again to the world origin.
And this is a good way. Is this really
how you spell been? I've been I I
remember I was once once I was taking a
math test and I took like math in
college, so you have to write proofs
with English. And I could not remember
how to spell of O F. I thought I just
couldn't remember. So I'm like, is it
UV? Is that how you spell bin? It just
looks so weird to me. I know this is
stupid, but I I'd feel stupider if I got
it wrong. Bin definition. The social
gathering where people Am I like having
a stroke right now? How do you spell
bin? I feel like I'm going nuts. Wait,
how do you spell bin? What about like
I've been thinking? That'll give me the
right spelling. Yeah, that's how you
spell it. I don't know. I don't know
what's happening to me. Like I can do
all this advanced geode stuff, but I
can't spell bin. Seems about right.
Okay, let's do another. And I'm actually
going to write this one down here so
that we can compare. You're not going to
see it from here, but always brush your
teeth, which is true. It's very
important. First, before I reveal it,
let's uh write this in here. Always
brush your teeth. And just like magic,
it's there. And we got to get rid of the
corner alphabet. So, always brush your
teeth. And let's compare it. So, get
this in your head. Okay. Let's make that
big. Always brush your teeth. Always
brush your teeth.
Yeah. Am I right? And if you wanted to
change this so it's like lighter,
darker, a different color, we use the
shader editor. So let's kind of find one
of our A's. I don't know which one it's
going to be. Is it this one? It is this
one. What I can do is I can mix. Maybe I
can mix color. I'm going to have this as
a factor and it can mix between pure the
bottom should be pure white and then
maybe the color red. So now I'm writing
in red. As a final thing, cuz we've put
in all this effort for it to be
procedural. Let's add a bit more
randomness. What do we think about that?
Going to look at our positioner, which
by the way, it's again just using a
field to translate. So, I could always
like I don't know, I can move it on the
Y-axis or whatever. I like this cuz now
the letters still won't cross each
other. Whereas, if I did the X, these
faces, these instances are now
intersecting. I'm going to pick a random
value maybe between minus1 and one. So,
I can go up or down. Do this for the Y.
Okay. And then we are going to multiply
by a tiny number. So just like just like
that. And that in itself can get a seed.
I think that makes it look way more
natural. So before after. So maybe this
can also be a uh group input. So this
can be our like Y variation or whatever.
And look at that. And now you might
think, oh, he's done. Like what a cool
tutorial. I saved something for you. I
saved a punch line. Right now all we're
doing is we're typing in here. We have
missing characters. We don't we can't
type a number. What if I wanted to take
a existing text file? Okay, can you see
where I'm going with this? I don't want
to write it. I just want to import it.
Well, you may or may not know there's a
import. Is there import text? There's a
import text node. What does this do? It
lets me pick a file, also a dynamic path
if I wanted to. So, this is a way to
type your homework and make it look like
you wrote it like for real. Let's make a
uh text file. So, I'm going to open up
Notepad. I'm going to save this to be
like our writing.ext.
And I believe I don't think it updates
unless we like refresh. I do know at
least this one's wrong. Sally sells
seashells. So let's kind of start with
that. And I'm going to save it. And then
for import text, I'm going to bring in
this. And let's see. Connect that in
here. So there we go. Sally sells
seashells by. And I'm going to save
that. And I think we have to reload it.
Yeah. By the just like that. I wonder if
a frame change counts as an update. So
let's see. I'm going to write something
and then I'm going to save. So let's do
hello and then I'm going to save. No, I
still have to reconnect that. I wonder
if there's a trick. I wonder if there's
a trick. Can I run simulation zone cuz I
do think this is a cool idea. So, I'm
going to run a simulation zone where the
only thing it changes is the um string
input. So, now I'm going to play this
and it's going to bake like a simulation
making sure the string is the same all
the time. So, if I delete everything and
I save. No. Could we put this inside the
simulation zone? Does that force a
reload? So, I'm going to say hello. I'm
going to save this. So, let's do a
refresh. And now I'm going to click
play. So, it's dynamic. Test. And then a
save.
Got him. Save. There you go. So, that's
how you force a reload.
So, uh there you go. You could write a
really long piece of text. You could
even like import a book or something and
make it look like you wrote it. The only
missing component is we need it to have
a sense of overflow. So, what that means
is it, you know, goes to a different
line or even better, it can look at the
file and see if there's a line break.
Yeah. Yeah. I do want to try that. I do
want to try that. Become a member at
cgmatter.com. Okay. I've earned it. H.
Okay. There we go, boys. Write me a
500word short story. Can't be line
breaks. Yeah, this is going to be a
beefy one cuz you could think of each
letter as a iteration. Boom. There's my
short story. Disconnect. Reconnect. It's
chugging. I have faith though. Okay, I
did it. This is weird to me cuz this is
my handwriting. Like to me, like you
might just think, "Oh, it's a thing."
But to me, this is my handwriting. Very
cool. Okay, I'm going to wrap it up. So,
uh, to get the finished blend, which is
going to be this, but I'm going to I I
mean, I don't know. I feel like I'm
going to take it further. I'm enjoying
it. Uh, website, become a member. $5 a
month. You get access to five years of
project files. And the the nodes, some
of the nodes that I imported in are
going to be free on my website as well.
So, while you visit, pay money. Just a
thought. Okay. Uh, thank you for
watching.